bonsoir
durant la pandémie vous aviez ouvert une
cantine une cantine code côtière qui
était devant votre établissement c'était
des conteneurs dans le stationnement de
l'église du Bic là vous vous installez à
saint Fabien dans le village voisin
pourquoi se déménagement puis pourquoi
le choix du modèle cantine
[Applaudissements]
évidemment
le fait d'avoir choisi le concept de
restauration rapide de cuisiner à
l'extérieur
c'était vraiment réponse à la pandémie
parce qu'on se rappelle que finalement
les établissements principalement de
restauration indépendante était fermée
pendant la pandémie donc ça répondait à
un besoin aussi de survie c'est à dire
nos marges de profit sont extrêmement
minces donc une crise comme la pandémie
annonçait déjà la perte de quelques
établissements donc loin de moi l'idée
de disparaître donc j'avais
conceptualisé
ces établissements finalement de
restauration rapide à l'extérieur ou
c'est possible de venir commander alors
à l'époque on se rappelle peu importe
quelle était la couleur c'est-à-dire
jaune rouge ou orange peu importe
c'était de servir la nourriture dans les
cantines mais là maintenant pourquoi la
cantine aujourd'hui encore on n'est plus
en pandémie mais est-ce que c'est encore
une réponse à la pandémie comment vous
situez ça
c'est encore une réponse à la pandémie
je vous dirais que économiquement la
pandémie a fait énormément mal aux
établissements de restauration à la
grandeur du Québec maintenant c'est un
choix
oui c'est un choix d'affaires en fait on
a désiré aussi s'installer dans un lieu
où c'était possible
d'installer aussi les containers parce
que on le rappelle aussi au Québec c'est
extrêmement difficile la législation ne
permet pas en général l'installation
de lieu de restauration temporaire on
voit food truck à Montréal et puis tout
ça mais sachez que c'est extrêmement
difficile
de percer cette offre là maintenant le
choix de la cantine
c'est je voudrais strictement parce que
j'ai un nouveau projet qui est celui de
démocratiser la gastronomie avec
les effets de la pandémie on se retrouve
avec une inflation avec une augmentation
du coût des denrées qui est notoire une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre donc il devient
vraiment extrêmement difficile pour des
restaurants de du registre de
gastronomie si je peux dire d'être
rentable donc la conception
et puis l'idée derrière la cantine c'est
le volume maintenant
absolument ça c'est sûr et certain je
vous dirais évidemment j'ai quand même
fait le choix de gastronomiser la
cantine donc oui effectivement de faire
la promotion des produits du
Saint-Laurent parce qu'elle est
frontière elle est juste derrière moi
elle est québécoise
donc voilà
évidemment je vous dirais ça répond
aussi à un besoin que j'ai moi de rester
vivante de rester là pour continuer à
faire la promotion de notre grand
patrimoine alimentaire québécois ça fait
quand même plusieurs années que vous
faites la promotion des crustacés des
poissons de l'Est du Québec de la
fantastique ça licorne les algues est-ce
que vous voyez un impact réel de ce
travail que vous menez que d'autres
mènent également mais que vous menez sur
les producteurs sur les consommateurs
également
oui absolument je vous dirais je pense
que le Québec est en transformation il
faut pas oublier que toute société est
réfractaire au changement mais on
accueille avec avec grand plaisir je le
vois par rapport à l'engouement des
consommateurs
des gens qui qui commence de plus en
plus à exiger que les produits soient
québécois à reconnaître le travail des
chefs cuisiniers des artisans aussi qui
sont d'illustre personnage de toute
notre patrimoine alimentaire donc je
vous dirais maintenant ce qui nous
manque c'est la part de nos
gouvernements
un intérêt grandissant pour pouvoir
faire la promotion et encourager pour
qu'elle puisse se développer encore
longtemps la
gastronomie québécoise est-ce que votre
grand restaurant Chez Saint-Pierre est
fermé pour de bon
non absolument
il est en réflexion en fait écouter nous
on essaie de trouver les moyens
on essaie de se les donner également
c'est bien involontaire de notre part
mais
c'était impossible pour nous par rapport
je vous dirai à plusieurs plusieurs
choses mais principalement la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui fait en sorte que
c'est difficile de conserver une
notoriété
quand on est peu pour pouvoir travailler
autour d'une réputation parce que je
dois la maintenir parce que ça fait
maintenant plus de 20 ans que le
restaurant existe donc j'imagine le
consommateur débarqué chez moi j'ai
envie d'être capable de lui assurer
finalement
ce dont il s'attend quand il vient
s'attablir chez moi et j'avais peur de
quoi être capable d'y arriver cette
année c'est très clair je mentionne que
ici télé diffuse ce soir la demi-finale
de la 12e saison de l'émission Les Chefs
dans laquelle vous jouez un rôle de
mentor alors on va regarder ça ce soir
sur Radio-Canada Colomb Saint-Pierre
merci merci d'avoir été avec nous bon
été Merci à VOUS bonne soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]